bonjour messieurs dames un petit chèvre
avec plaisir les i c'est un petit
éleveur là dans le larzac excellente
auteurs notent ils ont fait des promos
sur le brie de melun
n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir venez
goûter notre bleu de chèvre fermier il
est bon il et crémeux non vous
certainement passer du lait cru bonjour
madame un petit lunch être fermier
allez-y madame un petit chèvre
je les ai déjà abouti mais c'est
tellement bon et à les y ont vécu une
vie double de xiamen juste un petit bout
de fromage madame non j'ai une amie qui
a mangé du non pasteurisé son enfant est
né avec deux mains gauches
bonne dégustation et amusez-vous un
monsieur un petit bleu de chaque fermier
et il est bon il est créé me laissa plus
maintenant on me donne un peu de fromage
de quai
zhu pets et rots tu vas mettre un
colomiers à roblochon et un claque aux
droits trois claques que les matchs tu
veux pas te calmer là tu fais quoi tu
fêteras mutile toi va prendre du pain et
tu me fais une tarte auch il est là le
beurre ou jetant l a pas beaucoup le
temps
enfin quand même manger du lait cru
qu'on est enceinte franchement fernand
toi je vais te souffert tulle mais moins
du mot france 24 ou 36 mois d'affinage
d'un mois le max cilla si elles sont ce
qui soutient bon mais ça y est on peut y
aller maintenant
les moines clap nonceveux l'amnésie
[Musique]
jamais
n'approchez pas une once pilotage images
de son but alors attendez emma ne fait
rien que risquez de regretter
je sais que vous traverser une épreuve
difficile et je suis là pour qu'on en
parle d'accord qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour l'en soit pouvant manger du
fromage boire deux verres de vin par
jour et fumer une cigarette de temps en
temps d'accord mais on voulait pas de
l'argent une voiture ou un hélico pour
le secours elle est prête à tout elle
veut me tuer minimes 1 laurette m a
donné et emma sur une échelle de jolies
images je me mets à votre place et je
comprends votre colère
non non tu comprends pas non non pas ce
que pense à fait seul mois que je me
fais juste part des gens que je connais
pas sur ce que je dois manger ce que je
dois boire ce que je dois faire ou pas
faire mais je ne sais quoi tous ces
interdits à la cour là avant nos mères
elles pichonets fumer pendant leur
grossesse et était ok regardez je vais
très bien mais alors oui mais ça c'est
intéressant ça va parler - de votre
maman vous pas de ma gueule j'ai c'est
que tu essaie de gagner du temps non
mais qui s'y seraient prêts à se priver
de tout ce qu'il aime pendant neuf mois
voilà oui
merci moi mais moi je veux bien essayer
si ça peut te 2 d'où tu prends la
confiance toit reste à faire alors tu
dis c'est quoi mais je disais que je me
rendais pas compte que c'était aussi
difficile pour toi et que b je veux bien
essayer de me priver de plein de plaisir
tu ferais ça pour moi bah oui merci à
vous tous
[Musique]
pas moi
allez y est
rentrer à la maison mais on vers un peu
de tout on va rentrer parfait vaquer à
l'opération est terminée
le tissu plissé chimie